uh it's named the queen's green canopy
the initiative hopes to inspire the
planting of over a million trees while
it's doing pretty well so far joining me
now is tony juniper the environmentalist
and campaigner and tony i think you
you've met your first target haven't you
um
how many trees have already been planted
so far
well we estimate around a million went
in during the planting season that ran
from october last year to march this
year and we're hoping that when we get
into the planting round later on this
year from october onwards we might
achieve another million
and alongside the planting of trees and
encouraging people to get the right
trees in the right place the queen's
green canopy is also
marking the occasion of the platinum
jubilee with a network of 70 ancient
trees
and 70 ancient woodlands because they
remind us
about the sense of history really and
the monarch really is representing a
golden thread of uh the passage of time
going back a thousand years and indeed
many of the ancient trees across the
landscapes of this country across the
united kingdom are indeed considerably
older than that and one or two
individual trees uh would have been
growing during the time of the late
bronze age about 3000 years ago and so
the idea of planting trees for the
future
is also backed by a reminder of the role
of trees in history shaping the
landscape over very long periods of time
and if we do get the right trees in the
right place as a result of the planting
that will go on
during the jubilee time it may be that
those trees will be there in hundreds or
even thousands of years into the future
so it's marking that golden thread of
time that sense of history looking back
and looking forward and a lot of people
have been involved which is absolutely
fantastic and if you're an individual or
a village or a community group or an
organization or a major business or a
small business everyone can get involved
and if you go to the queen's green
canopy website you can find the
resources there to help you get the
right tree into the right place
and of course the queen has been seen
planting trees it seems since time
immemorial perhaps before we really
fully realized and appreciated the
significance of what she was doing how
many do we think that she's actually
planted over her raid
well the estimate is that it's more than
1 500 that she has personally put into
the ground uh during the course of her
time serving as queen which i work out
about one of fortnight which is a pretty
prodigious
tree planting race and if we all did
that obviously there would be a lot more
trees
in the world um but it's very important
to to make sure you're choosing the
right kind of tree for the right purpose
and getting them into the right place we
don't actually want trees everywhere
some beautiful open habitats like
ancient grasslands and heathlands and
peatlands uh very often are better off
without trees but that leaves many many
places where we could do well by having
more of them to catch carbon from the
atmosphere
to be cleaning up the air that we
breathe
to be providing a home for wildlife in
some landscapes they can help help
reduce the flow of water off of the land
thereby helping to reduce flood risk and
so if we're thoughtful about this we can
get some enormous benefits for the
country now and long into the future if
everyone joins in with with the queen's
green canopy initiative
thanks so much really good to talk to
you thank you